calme quand nous sommes
rentrés à Orikhiv.
Pourtant, de jour en jour,
la guerre se rapproche.
Sur la place centrale,
quelques fermiers ont même
installé leur étal ce matin.
"Lejojours de marché avant,
dit Oleg, la place était
pleine de monde. Les gens
Aujourd'hui, chacun se dépêche
de faire quelques courses.
"Je peux seulement prier,etetet
je ne souhaite qu'une chose,
dit-elle, c'est la paix."
Quelques instanlululus tard...
(sirène)
C'est le temps de rentrer.
Pas de panique,
juste de
Tamara, qui espérait faire
quelques sous aujourd'hui,
"C'est chaque jour la même
un peu excédée. Des sirènes,
des bombes, e e e peut pas
dormir, c'est terrifiant."
(bombardements)
Nous nous dirigeons
vers les quartiers plus
près de la ligne de front.
À l'aube, c'est un jardin
d'enfants qui a été touché.
Les Russes y ont largué
une bombe. Hoioioioioioioioioio.
Il n'y a pas eu de victimes.
(bombardements)
Pendant que nous sommes là,
rsrsrsrs se rapprochent.
Les rues sont pratiquement
désertes. Une bonne partieuiuiué
la ville, les femmes etlelelele.
Il reste les hommes
qui doivent se battre etâââââââs
qui n'ont pas les moyens de
s'en aller et qui se retrouvent
dans des conditions extrêmement
difficiles.
ananananananananananananananana,
les Russes viennent de frapper
cet entrepôt de semences.
Le blé devait servir à nourrir
la popul
La voie ferrée a été endommagée
et le voisinage brûle.
combats se poursuivent ainsi.
Les Ukrainiens résistent.
En fac l l l l les troupes
russes seraient importantes.
Elles occupent déjà
Et si Orikhiv tombait,
Moscou pourrait élargir
le territoire déjà contrôlé
du Donbass. Mais la mairesse
adjointe nous assure
sans le moindre doute
que cela n'arrivera pas.
"Nous sommes plus forts,
on est chez nous, dit-elle,
On l'était, on l'est,lelelelele"
(bombardements)s s s s s s s s t
dans les immeubles abandonnés,ss
s'aventurent à l'extérieur.
La plupart dépendentviviviviviv.
Ellesfefefefefefefefefefefefef,
dit Valentina. Elle s'occupe
de sa mère de 87 ans et
ne veut pas s'en aller.
"Qui peut nous ai-e-e-e-e-e-e-.
Aidez-nous! J'ai mes enfants,
mes petits-enfants et
je ne peux pas les voir.
C'est trop dan
Comme tous ceux qui restent,
Valentina se prépare
au prochain bombardement.
pourquoi la Russie s'acharne
sur eux. Ils menaient une
si tranquille, avant.
(bombardements)
Céline Galipeau,
Radio-Canada, Orikhiv